Love Island, Prince Charming, Temptation Island:
Trash-TV spaltet die Nation. Die einen lieben es,
die anderen hassen es. Trotzdem, oder... genau
deshalb ist Reality-TV super erfolgreich!
2021 machte der Anteil von Reality-TV
sogar teilweise über 40 Prozent aus.
Was aber wenn diese Sendungen ein
Millionenpublikum dümmer machen?
Das behaupten super viele Artikel und
erklärte Gegner von Trash-TV. Angeblich
steckt da sogar echte Wissenschaft hinter…
und hier sind wir misstrauisch geworden.
Wir haben uns diese Studien
zu Trash-TV für euch genauer
angeschaut – und so viel kann man schon mal sagen:
Heute geht es um schlechten Journalismus,
herzlich willkommen auf Doktor Whatson
Wenn wir Trash-TV sagen, dann meinen wir meistens:
Reality TV. Und RealityTV bedeutet: gewöhnlich
wirkende Menschen in ganz alltäglich aussehenden
Situationen. Dabei sollen die Kandidaten sehr
authentisch rüberkommen und die Handlungen wirken
alle recht spontan. Außerdem werden konventionelle
Erzählstrukturen gebrochen, da gerade das
Unvorhersehbare die Zuschauer so fesselt.
Und das kann natürlich Spaß machen.
Wir Menschen schnüffeln eben gerne
in der Privatsphäre anderer Menschen
herum. Und Reality-TV bietet genau das.
Man könnte diese Formate also einfach unter die
Kategorie “Unterhaltung” stecken und das
Ganze nicht zu ernst nehmen.Aber dann
geistern eben noch solche Meldungen durch
die Medien: “Dschungelcamp, "Love Island"
und Co: Macht Trash-TV dumm?” , “Forscher
bestätigt: Trash-TV lässt Hirn schrumpfen” und
“Wissenschaftler weisen nach, dass
viel Trash-TV dem Gehirn schadet”.
Aber: Stimmt das überhaupt? Wir haben uns
einmal durch all diese Artikel gegraben und
etwas Spannendes gefunden: Sie haben alle
voneinander abgeschrieben. Eine bedeutende
Mehrheit der Artikel bezieht sich auf
eine Studie von Ryan J. Dougherty. Der
ist Professor für Neurologie an einer Hochschule
für öffentliche Gesundheit. Cool, klingt ja nach
guter Wissenschaft und gutem Journalismus,
aber ich würde gutes Geld darauf wetten,
dass kein einziger dieser Journalisten
jemals die Studie selber gelesen hat.
Doch bevor wir uns die Studie
mal etwas genauer anschauen…was
bedeutet es eigentlich dumm zu werden?
Und lässt sich das überhaupt messen?
Gemessen wird “Dummheit” ironischerweise
meist über Intelligenz. Aber hier liegt
auch schon ein großes Problem: Auch
wenn es oft so angenommen wird,
streng genommen ist Dummheit nicht
genau das Gegenteil von Intelligenz.
Auch intelligente Menschen können sich “dumm”
verhalten oder sind in einzelnen Entscheidungen
"dumm". Dazu haben wir übrigens ein ganzes Video
gemacht: Warum schlaue Menschen dumme Dinge sagen.
Und ein anderes Problem: es gibt gar keine
einheitliche Definition von Intelligenz,
da es ein von der Gesellschaft
erschaffenes Konzept ist.
Die meisten Psychologen halten sich an die
Definition, dass Intelligenz die Fähigkeit ist,
aus Erfahrung zu lernen, Probleme zu lösen
und sich an neue Situationen anzupassen. In
der Wissenschaft sind aber noch viele
Fragen in Bezug zur Intelligenz offen,
zum Beispiel ob es sich bei der Intelligenz
um eine Gesamt-Fähigkeit handelt oder um viele
einzelne Fähigkeiten. Und ob man Intelligenz im
Gehirn überhaupt lokalisieren kann, ist auch noch
offen . Eines ist jedoch sicher: Intelligenz ist
eine Kombination aus genetischen Veranlagungen
und Umweltfaktoren. Das heißt: Wie schlau wir
sind, kann durch äußere Faktoren, wie Bildung,
Erfahrung und Training beeinflusst werden. Und
das kann vielleicht auf Trash-TV einschließen.
Trotzdem ist es sehr schwierig, Intelligenz
richtig zu messen. Dafür gibt es bislang
hauptsächlich zwei verschiedene Wege: Erstens
können wir Intelligenztests verwenden. Der wohl
bekannteste von Ihnen ist der IQ-Test.
Zum anderen lässt sich Intelligenz über
Gehirnstrukturen bestimmen, zum Beispiel
über den Anteil von grauer Hirnsubstanz.
Je höher die Menge an grauer Substanz in
bestimmten Hirnregionen ist und je mehr
Synapsen dort ausgebildet sind, desto
intelligenter soll ein Mensch sein.
Doch beide Wege haben ihre Vor- und Nachteile und
generell ist die Messung von Intelligenz einfach
sehr komplex. Alleine z. B. unterschiedliche
kulturelle Prägungen gerecht zu berücksichtigen,
ist ganz schön knifflig – so knifflig, dass
es ein eigenes Video werden könnte. Wenn
euch das also interessiert, schreibt
uns das gerne Mal in die Kommentare.
Aber Kommen wir nun zu der eigentlichen Studie
- Wird man durch Trash-TV nun dümmer? Die kurze
Antwort: Wir wissen es nicht – denn darum
ging es in der Studie gar nicht! Kein Scherz.
In der Studie ging es eigentlich zum
einen, ganz generell um den Fernsehkonsum,
und das ganz unabhängig vom Inhalt. Und zum
anderen ging es um die Auswirkung davon auf
die allgemeine Gehirngesundheit– nicht explizit
Intelligenz. Gehirngesundheit wurde hier unter
anderem im Zusammenhang mit späteren Alzheimer-
oder Demenz-Erkrankungen in Verbindung gebracht.
Ok, aber fangen wir mal von vorne an: Das
eigentliche Ziel der Studie war es herauszufinden,
ob die Effekte vom Fernsehgucken auf das
Gehirn nur darauf zurückzuführen sind,
dass wir dabei sitzen. Oder ob das Fernsehgucken
selber zusätzlich negative Effekte hervorruft.
Dass Bewegung generell immer besser ist,
als nichts tun, ist nichts Neues. Aber ob
es einen Unterschied macht, welche Art
der sitzenden Tätigkeiten wir ausüben,
das ist eben noch nicht ganz klar. Und
genau das wollte die Studie herausfinden.
Um das mal eben festzuhalten: Es geht in der
viel-zitierten Studie also weder um Trash-TV,
noch um Intelligenz und eigentlich
auch ziemlich viel ums Sitzen.
Dafür wurden in einem Zeitraum von 20 Jahren die
Entwicklung der grauen Gehirnsubstanz beobachtet,
die tägliche Fernsehdauer notiert, sowie die
sonstigen körperlichen Tätigkeiten erfasst.
Und tatsächlich: die Ergebnisse deuten darauf
hin, dass der Fernsehkonsum selbst eine Rolle
für die Gesundheit des Gehirns spielt. Ein
hoher Fernsehkonsum über die 20 Jahre hinweg
hat das Volumen der grauen Gehirnsubstanz von
den Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmern tatsächlich
verringert. Und dieser Effekt konnte auch nicht
durch sonstige körperliche Aktivität aufgehoben
werden. Also nochmal zusammengefasst:
Fernsehkonsum spielt unabhängig davon,
dass es eine sitzende Tätigkeit ist, eine
Rolle für die Gesundheit des Gehirns. Und
zu dem Entschluss sind auch andere Studie
gekommen. Die haben wir euch wie immer
ganz transparent in der Videobeschreibung
zusammen mit allen anderen Quellen verlinkt.
Hatte Mama damals also vielleicht doch recht, mit
ihrem: Zu lange Fernsehschauen macht dumm? Jaaaa,
aber hier ist es wichtig zu betonen: die Studie
spricht von einem zu langen Fernsehkonsum... Und
damit sind vor allem mehr als 3,5 Stunden täglich
über einen langen Zeitraum hinweg gemeint. Und
Fernsehschauen bleibt dabei nur einer von vielen
Faktoren, der die Gehirngesundheit bestimmt. Auch
körperliche Aktivitäten, Alter und das generelle
Bildungsniveau spielen für die Gesundheit des
Gehirns eine Rolle. Die Studie rund um Ryan
J. Dougherty räumt selber ein, dass es noch
weitere zusätzliche Gewohnheiten gibt, die mit dem
Fernsehkonsum einhergehen können, wie Ernährung,
Schlaf und soziale Faktoren, die sie in der
Studie jedoch gar nicht kontrollieren konnten.
Außerdem steht bei all den
Studien auch wieder das “Huhn-Ei:
Was war zuerst da?”-Problem im Raum. Eine
Studie hat zumindest im Zusammenhang mit
aggressivem Verhalten und TV-Konsum die
Theorie aufgestellt,dass nicht unbedingt
Fernsehgucken aggressiv macht, sondern
eventuell aggressive Personen einfach
mehr Fernsehgucken. Um das sicher sagen zu
können, braucht es aber noch mehr Studien.
Aber wie kam es denn dann zu den Headlines,
dass Trash TV dumm macht, wenn das doch gar
nicht in der Studie gesagt wird? Die traurige
aber simple Antwort: schlechter Journalismus.
In dem konkreten Fall lief das ganze so ab:
Der allererste Artikel, den wir finden konnten,
hat die Studie noch korrekt zitiert:
"The proof is in: TV really does rot your
brain." – Allerdings hat der Journalist auch seine
eigene Meinung in den Bericht einfließen lassen,
was an sich nicht dramatisch wäre. Da er selbst
leidenschaftlicher Filme- und Serien-Gucker ist,
und das sogar täglich und ausgiebig tut,
wollte er die Ergebnisse scheinbar nicht so
ganz wahrhaben. Deswegen hat er die Ergebnisse an
seine Ansichten angepasst. Und das ist nicht ok.
So kam er zu dem Schluss, dass vermutlich nur
"schlechte Inhalte" negative Auswirkungen auf
das Gehirn haben – also Trash-TV. Da er solche
Inhalte aber selber nicht schaut, muss er sich
glücklicherweise wohl doch keine Sorgen machen.
Auch wenn das gar nicht die Aussage der Studie
war! Aber immerhin war bei ihm noch relativ gut zu
erkennen, was Studien-Inhalt und was Meinung ist.
Leider griffen spätere Journalisten hauptsächlich
nur die persönliche Meinung auf und präsentierten
sie in ihren Artikeln wie das offizielle Ergebnis
der Studie. Herauskam dann: “Forscher bestätigt:
Trash TV lässt Hirn schrumpfen”. Aaaaargh.
Und dass das alles so passiert ist,
zeigt sich nicht nur daran, dass die anderen
Artikel später veröffentlicht wurden, sondern
vor allem daran, dass die anderen Journalisten
den ersten Artikel als Quelle verlinkt haben…
Leider sind solche Headlines nicht selten. Euch
allen sind wahrscheinlich auch schon Schlagzeilen,
wie diese über den Weg gelaufen: ”Jeden
Tag ein Glas Wein trinken ist gesund"
,“”ältere Geschwister sind die schlechteren
Autofahrer”, “Oreos wirken wie Heroin” oder auch
die immer wieder sehr falsch wiedergegebene
Schweden-Studie, die gesagt haben soll,
dass E-Autos ihren CO2-Fußabdruck
erst nach 8 Jahren wieder einholen.
All diese Aussagen, die sich nach nem
kurzen Faktencheck als wissenschaftlich
nicht haltbar herausstellen,
und nun in der Welt kursieren,
haben Journalistinnen und Journalisten
verbockt – wissentlich oder eben nicht.
Und teilweise gibt es hinter solchen vermeintlich
wissenschaftlichen Aussagen noch nicht einmal eine
wissenschaftliche Quelle. Manche Fakten entstehen
durch reine Marketingzwecke. So wie bei dem Fakt,
dass “man 10.000 Schritte am Tag
gehen soll”. Das war eine reine
Verkaufsstrategie einer japanischen Firma, die
Schrittzähler verkaufen wollte. Und weil diese
damals nur maximal 10.000 Schritte erfassen
konnten… könnt ihr euch vermutlich denken,
auf welchen genialen Kniff die
Werbe-Agentur gekommen sein muss.
Und trotzdem wird es von der
Presse weiterhin so verbreitet,
als wäre es ein wissenschaftlich bewiesener
Fakt. Es ist also eigentlich kein großes Wunder,
dass das Verhältnis zwischen
Wissenschaft und Medien fast
weltweit als unbefriedigend empfunden
wird. Und das ist furchtbar schade…
Was nehmen wir jetzt also daraus mit? Es ist
wichtig einen kritischen Blick auf journalistische
Arbeit zu haben. Man sollte nicht einfach
jeder Schlagzeile blind vertrauen. Am besten
wäre es natürlich, selbst nochmal alle Quellen zu
überprüfen, aber dafür hat man natürlich selten
die Zeit und das ist auch eigentlich nicht unser
Job. Wir haben hier also wirklich ein Problem,
wenn wir nicht wollen, dass bald
niemand mehr den Medien vertraut.
Aber gleichzeitig gibt es natürlich gar nicht
“die Medien” als Einheit, sondern unterschiedliche
Häuser mit unterschiedlichen Standards. Ich
persönlich versuche meine Nachrichten nur von
qualitativ hochwertigen Medien zu bekommen.
Aber natürlich machen auch die Fehler und
haben ihre Biases, deswegen gilt weiterhin:
Augen auf, kritisch sein und Doktor Whatson
gucken! Denn hier gibt’s auf jeden Fall gut
recherchierte Videos über Wissenschaft. Und
wenn ihr hiervon Fans seid, dann hab ich
jetzt eine spannende Empfehlung für euch.
Der Sponsor dieses Videos ist nämlich die
plus-MINT Talentförderung. Das ist ein
Förderprogramm für junge Menschen mit besonderen
Interessen und Fähigkeiten im MINT-Bereich. Wenn
ihr also Stärken in Mathematik, Informatik,
Biologie, Chemie, Physik oder Technik habt
und diese gerne ausbauen wollt, dann sind die
plus-MINT Internate genau das Richtige für euch.
An den Internaten habt ihr einen geregelten
Tagesablauf mit Fokus auf euer Spezialgebiet
im MINT-Bereich. Ihr könnt viel mehr forschen
und euch mit Wissenschaft auseinandersetzen
als bisher und habt abends auch noch die
Möglichkeit mit Freunden Sport zu treiben
oder andere AGs wie Robotik, Segeln oder
Magic The Gathering zu machen. Bewerben
können sich Schülerinnen und Schüler, die jetzt
in der 8 oder 9. Klasse sind und die sich durch
besondere Leistungen z.B. bei Jugend forscht,
den Science Olympiaden, dem Mathe Känguru oder
anderen Wettbewerben hervorgetan haben und
natürlich auch schulisch besonders gut sind.
Die Bewerbungsphase ist heute gestartet und
geht noch bis zum 1. März des kommenden Jahres.
Falls eure Neugier jetzt geweckt
ist, dann schaut doch mal über
den ersten Link in der Beschreibung
auf plus minus mint punkt de vorbei.
Ich kann es euch persönlich nach
bestem Wissen und Gewissen empfehlen,
denn ich habe inzwischen mehrere Internate
besucht und war jedes Mal beeindruckt.
Meine Besuche haben wir natürlich auch
gefilmt. Diese Videos könnt ihr euch jetzt
hier ansehen und es kommen auch bald noch
mehr auf dem YouTube-Kanal von plus-MINT.